sous les casques la crème du cyclisme
féminin des médaillés olympiques des
championnes d'europe et championnes du
monde qui ont pris l'habitude de
terminer l'été sur les routes du cher
300 km d'effort au travers du sud berry
et de ses villages tranquilles
à force de détermination le trophée d'or
s'est fait un nom et vivra cette année
sa vingtième édition
un petit miracle pour son organisateur
marc parisse à cinq mois de la course
il a les yeux rivés sur les chiffres et
ceux de son budget encore loin d'être
bouclé la question qu'on me pose c'est
quelle est la rentabilité alors c'est
quelle quelle rentabilité on peut avoir
dans une course aussi this mais
n'importe laquelle
en plus on vous dit oui mais c'est un
sport féminin je dis oui c'est un sport
féminin c'est vrai et je pense que c'est
ça c'est que les gens à l'heure actuelle
non non on parle du sport féminin on le
on essaye on dit oui on va on va aider
le sport féminin mais moi je dis non non
non c'est pas vrai vous ne l'êtes pas en
ce moment elle est justement comme là on
est en train d'enterrer là pour
maintenir cet événement il faut trouver
chaque année 125 mille euros une somme
raisonnable dans le milieu des courses
internationales mais un véritable casse
tête pour l'organisateur surtout lorsque
des partenaires historiques se désengage
cette année c'est la ville de
saint-amand montrond berceau de
l'épreuve qui a fait faux bond et
renoncer à verser les vingt-sept mille
euros nets annuels
quand il ya eu l'augmentation est
important des frères qui fait la
sécurité c'est là qu'on a senti que le
trophée d'or a été serré serré et on a
justement nous maintenant les
collectivités
on est dans la même dynamique où la
baisse des dotations fait que on
essaierait un moment il ya peu plus
d'oxygène
moi je vous propose de lorsqu'on arrive
rue des coupes en prendre à droite rue
lamartine avenue victor hugo de musset
et après l'avenue du 11 novembre qui
nous fait revenir rue du général de
gaulle sans le soutien des communes pas
de course alors le trophée d'or s'est
résolu à s'exporter dans le nord du
département
l'ama à saint-doulchard on a accepté de
débourser entre 10 et 15 mille euros
pour accueillir le départ d'une étape
saint doulchard a pris de l'importance
ils nous ont aidé énormément l'année
dernière suite à un désistement de
la communauté de communes de la septaine
et grâce à eux on a pu faire quatre
jours la dernière séance un mouchard ce
serait compliqué par exemple oui parce
qu'il faudrait encore retrouver une
ville est à l'heure actuelle les villes
sont pas là pour pour dire venez venez
venez et oui si sa douche harnes n'avait
pas encore pris cette année c'est vrai
que ça a été encore très dur après deux
années compliquées
difficile de se projeter la 20e édition
du trophée d'or aura bien lieu mais ce
pourrait être la dernière
comme cette classic de l'indre 2014
un plateau superbe des conditions
parfaites des spectateurs nombreux cette
année là énorme succès pour la jeune
coursannais en 2004 à châteauroux
on a réussi à bien tous maîtrisés de
partout on était en fait dans les
villages dans les communes c'était
génial on se serait cru au tour de
france derrière les belles images une
réalité plus complexe avec cinq cent
mille euros de budget 1200 bénévoles à
gérer des règles de sécurité drastiques
la classic de l'indre trophée fenioux
exigé beaucoup de travail et malgré une
organisation bien huilée
l'équipe s'est essoufflé en pleine
apogée de la course c'était quand même
s'il vaudra parce que des
insatisfactions décor qui devait venir
qui sont pas venus enfin le directeur
sportif qui nous promettait monts et
merveilles ou vie sera là et puis la
veille quand il prévenait ce que
certains provenaient même pas donc
et puis bon le pen partenaires maquis
qui partait à l'âge de la retraite et il
y en a qui sont plus indispensables que
l'autre et là je viens c'est une
foultitude une multitude d'événements de
causes qui ont fait prendre cette
décision
pendant que certaines courses
disparaissent d'autres s'ancre
durablement en région centre val de
loire paris bourges en est le parfait
exemple
franck rousse de la dirigé de 1998 à
et quand ils fassent la main l'événement
est à bout de souffle son successeur
laurent planches on change la donne
il faut du renouvellement si on veut que
la coursive et ce qu'a très bien c'est
que paris bouge à beaucoup de succession
et avec des gens jeunes leur en planches
on a moins de 50 ans donc il est très
jeune
alors moi de mon temps mais bénévole la
moyenne d'âge ont été entre 65 et 70 ans
donc très très difficile de faire tout
quand même avec des gens qui ont le
dynamisme mais bon il en plus ils n'ont
plus battant et au jour d'aujourd'hui je
pense que la moyenne est retombé autour
de 50 ans donc c'est très très bien pour
les futures années petit changement
c'est que la semaine dernière on n'avait
pas pu faire cinq heures donc fait à
mercredi ont fait une longue sortie et
le mérite après une sortie un peu plus
dynamique
nous on va prendre de la place pour ces
jeunes du pôle espoirs de
saint-amand-montrond
le futur c'est le haut niveau les
courses professionnelles et pour s'y
préparer rien de tel que de nos
entraînements et quelques moments
privilégiés au contact des plus grands
coureurs lors de courses d'international
dans la région on les voit des fois la
télé et c'est vraiment bien de les voir
en vrai après ça nous fait rêver déjà
par rapport à nous dit qu'on est là pour
être pro et quand on les voit on se dit
que c'est vraiment ça qu'on veut faire
et est-ce qu'on voit aussi le travail
qui reste à faire
ouais on voit la marge de progression
qui à accomplir
du rêve du spectacle du dépassement de
soi depuis 1880 la région a accueilli
des dizaines de course cycliste
internationale et a tiré en zones
rurales les plus grands noms de la
discipline
une réussite qui repose sur des
bénévoles dévoués et passionnés
aujourd'hui de moins en moins nombreux